what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here on the lord's day one of
the check-in you know me
i'm always checking up in the lord's day
making sure you're still black you're
beautiful you're happy
it's october [__] 11th already you
know what i'm saying i got my little
blue [__] uh long sherman little vest
on ain't that cold i just wanted to put
it on for effect you know what i'm
saying
but we're here with queer it's [__]
sunday
every sunday before football uncle joey
shows up i know some games started
already but
i've been doing things you know what i'm
saying
i figured we'd smoke a number here of
this [__] death
lord's og it's got communion
biscuits in it so we killed two birds
with one stone
we smoke a number duluth we get to see
each other
check in with each other make sure
everybody loves each other
and all that [__] you know i'm
saying i got a busy week
i know you [__] got a busy week
we all got busy weeks you know i'm
saying
some people are up some people are done
what are you going to do
you got to push forward [__] covert
they're scaring you the numbers
who gives a [__] you got to do what the
[__] you got to do
look at me i got one foot in the grave
one banana peel people around me are
dying i gotta go to a [__] weight
tomorrow
two i've been here what nine [__]
weeks already not not even two
two months two months this week i gotta
go to my second week he's a dear friend
rest his soul but you gotta do this this
is it
i gotta put myself in a cold video
situation you know what i'm saying
what's happening brother everything all
right
in your world look at these people
driving by like they know me i'm saying
nobody knows nothing but i hope you're
well
helped follow me on patreon and twitter
i've been having a good time lately i'm
here
my daughter and wife and my friends went
down the shore
so i got the [__] cars out of the loo
for the afternoon you know i'm saying
i can't smoke inside but i could smoke a
number outside so i come out here
and i said with you [__] for a
minute or two check in
you know the same [__] nothing changes
i just want you to know i'm here i'm
here and i'm doing my thing i'll be out
wednesday night uncle vinnie is looking
you know
i'm uh i don't got asthma i got sleep
apnea which is worse i've been smoking
reef for 30 [__] years
i swam in the hudson you know i got
underlying conditions who the [__] knows
but you know you got to go out you got
to keep living your life
well he's got this locked down the
governor [__] you this government is
great i don't know about your [__]
government i don't know i don't know
nothing everybody know everybody knows
nothing
whatever taxes don't know nothing all i
know is
it's a beautiful [__] day to be alive
you're alive
you got food you're watching football
well you just got a little [__]
opportunity to watch your uncle joey
smoke my number with you check in with
you let you know he's thinking about you
who the [__] does that was the last time
your grandfather
sent you a [__] video of himself
smoking a [__] number done
he loves you huh all right then go [__]
yourself this is what i'm talking about
people
don't get me started don't make me
[__] why you want to give that
[__] indian jet you know what i'm
saying
don't get me [__] started because i'm
ready to go anyway
i'm ready to go the fear has been
eliminated
i'm breathing again you know which is
good
we all went through our own [__] uh
quarantined [__] uh you know
whatever's
we moved so that was good i still love
my wife she still loves me
what do you want from me that said i'm
happy happy wife happy life right that's
what they say
so that's how i do it i keep it nice and
easy
i'm gonna eat some lunch and then i'm
gonna watch the game just like you on
the lord's day
i watched the honeymooners last night
very nice [__] harvey and the one
when they went to minneapolis
and he handcuffed him to the thing ralph
you mind if i smoke
i wouldn't care if you burned tremendous
i was still laughing by myself like a
[__] 10 year old you know
but that's me guys listen you got to
keep laughing
you got to keep your spirits up with
mental health wellness
aware day yesterday or whatever mental
health
awareness day am i aware that i'm
[__] crazy yes i'm aware do i control
it
yeah that's it do i go talk to somebody
no i make youtube videos and talk to you
[__] moocs you know i'm saying
what's better who's better than me i'm
gonna go pay some [__]
dodo a deuce and i have to [__]
listen to my problems i'm on the couch
that's how [__] it all starts next
thing you know they're touching you
they're finger banging and then you want
to complain well
you know get it together just talk to
youtube somebody will answer back
eventually
and if they answer back listen you don't
know nothing you don't want to know
the cops i don't know nothing i don't
know what you're talking about i don't
even know what youtube is
something else some guy hacked my
computer and put my [__]
uh sex tapes up i'm saying
[__] dummies who the [__] lets your
sex tape sleep
leak how the [__] do you do that who
makes [__] sex tapes what type of
people are you
i'm a catholic i don't i don't even like
myself you know
i don't want to watch myself [__] me
[__] somebody who
and then the other the sex tape leaked
how the [__] does it leak
how the [__] that my toilet leaks
i'm so happy to be out of there i could
jump up and down
my sex tape leaked unfucking believable
i don't know how
cool and a lot of these people they
steal your phone i got my phone in my
pocket nobody touches nothing
i'm one of those tricky [__] i
cut the pocket out so if you go in my
pocket you touch my dick you know what
i'm saying
i got i got a guy i still got it
it's the lord's day [__] with
uncle joey
i'm happy you're here
i'm happy you still got my back and i'm
happy we got [__] youtube
you know i'm saying we can do what we
want here smoke a little tootsie roots
and say hello to each other i'm the
[__] lord's day what other country
let you do that
how who who's better than me wednesday
nights
57 years old a man immigrant goes up on
the stage
cracks [__] jokes and they pay him
money are you [__]
crazy only this isn't this is the united
states of america
don't forget the vote either
am i voting i don't know if they reached
out to me
if like one of the two dudes reached out
to me and said listen
we know you're a felon we know you got
problems
but we know you give a [__] and you want
a better america
when you vote then maybe i'll [__]
give them a call i don't know
you know me trump's got my number ain't
they know
biden don't know about me but kavanaugh
harris come on stop
she's been to a couple of weed spots you
know what i'm saying
i've seen her in [__] with a mask on
with a [__] wig making believe she's
somebody else you know
but anyway that's it and that's that i'm
over here
smoking the [__] joint of life with
you guys
on the lord's day i wanted to check in
let you know uncle joey kiss and that's
it
patreon.com slash joey diaz
or [__] mad flavor on twitter or
whatever the [__] you you're thinking of
doing
what i'm saying i got everything except
lincoln then
i don't [__] with those successful
people you know what i'm saying
i stay black don't forget uncle joey
loves you
and i'll see you during the week
somewhere [__]